[Applause]
yes
yes welcome to the show
everybody uh stellar program tonight
hilarious comedian beth stelling is
going to be joining us
also joining us a packed house
that's right we have a full full crowd
again tonight because as you probably
know
we borrowed a page from major league
sports
and we decided to fill our audience
with cardboard cutouts you the fans
sent us your photos we printed them out
and here they are we had close to 20
000 submissions i think and here we've
packed the audience completely full
and uh fantastic in fact
it's so full that we have a standby line
that's right we have a standby line
outside the theater
look at that that takes dedication those
are people
we have record heat yep record
temperatures those are people that are
braving
those temperatures because cardboard is
flammable
they are braving those temperatures
outside
that's how popular this show is andy
it's unbelievable
people outside it's unbelie we are we
are the number one show
among the one-dimensional crowd i guess
it's two-dimensional
yeah yeah yeah no among cardboard
cutouts we are the number one show
yep we scored very highly any
interesting people
around you that we should check out yeah
he i'm not sure he's loving the show
yeah
but see with these two together it's
like it tells a story about somebody
made a stinky
okay see he's like you and she's like
oops
what about across the aisle andy who's
over there
oh my god there's a beat poet oh look at
that yeah look at that guy
he's got he's he's i've heard his poetry
is uh
very daring in the 1950s very
confrontational
yeah he's ready to duke it out yeah um
there's a lady with a fancy hat oh i
like her hat yeah we don't get we don't
get too many ladies with fancy hats you
know what i like i like it it's like the
old days when people dressed up to go to
a table right
what's wrong with you you dirty beatnik
um let's see what else we got back here
uh looks like uh either a
paranoid or an eco-terrorist i'm gonna
go with eco-terrorists good it's it's
sexier
um let's see okay
i'm against this do you think that guy
is pleasuring himself back there i think
he may be
i mean it's hard with no arms but he's
still managing
to do it well let me say
i can attest it can be done with no arms
and if you're gonna do it with no arms
the back row is the best place certainly
is
just well i i am just so excited that
not only are these people here but as i
said again
there's a standby line outside people
who couldn't get into the theater
braving record la temperatures waiting
for a chance for someone here
to uh to die i think